what I've learned is this is something
everyone's concerned about but it's not
always something that people know how to
go about fixing high school students
really close to my age are actually
interested and being prepared what the
future is going to give them after high
school like the teachers really like
having us there because it's a change of
pace for the students I think that we're
able to add to what they're teaching in
the classroom and get the students more
engaged we teach the basic lessons we
start off with the basics we start with
budgeting we start with goal-setting
which is an interesting one to put into
a financial literacy class but a very
relevant one because you have to know
why you're doing all these things with
your money we also get to more advanced
topics like real estate talk about what
exactly is a mortgage what does it mean
to refinance it buying a car so how much
does it cost to maintain per year people
don't always factor that cost in and
it's definitely not something you hear
about as a high school student we work
with foster children also charter
schools and traditional high schools
each site in each student is different
and their needs are different so just
being able to have this kind of wide
perspective on the needs and the types
of students that we serve help me think
more creatively and how we can tailor
our curriculum to the needs of each
specific student that we serve I chose
money think because not only is it a big
outreach to the community you got to
talk to locals you get to work with
students but also you get to give
something back at the same time so I
thought that was a good win-win for me
we break up into small groups and we sit
down with maybe four or five students
and we just talked to them through
normal conversation going in and
speaking with the students that's a
league different from what I did before
the students talk to you they give you
the progress on how that we expend not
just in money thing but beyond in their
life and how they've implemented what
I've taught them in the classroom in
their life and how that's impacted them
I never expected to have that kind of
experience and I'm so glad I did one of
our sites just ended this past week and
they only have one question when can we
start again
you